[Musica]
immaginiamo di andare tutti insieme a
visitare un museo archeologico siciliano
uno qualsiasi sceglietelo voi ecco
entriamo e cominciamo a camminare perché
sale
siamo letteralmente accerchiati da
reperti di qualsiasi genere ci sono
stati di marmo ci sono basi finemente
decorati ci sono monete e gioielli ma
anche anonime anfore pentole pesi da
telaio e perché no terrecotte tutte
noiosamente uguali
eppure ciascuno di questi oggetti è un
caleidoscopio di informazioni di storie
e se la storia che ci catapultano in
un'altra dimensione in un altro mondo un
mondo molto lontano dalla nostra
frenetica contemporaneità
un mondo che pullula di culti forse oggi
difficilmente comprensibili e miti molto
affascinanti ambientati nella maggior
parte dei casi proprio qua in sicilia
pensate ad esempio al mito di demetra e
kore quello che viene adoperato un po
banalmente per spiegarsi l'alternarsi
delle stagioni
oppure ancora alla storia della ninfa
aretusa una bella ragazza greca che
cerca di sfuggire alle avance di un
focoso dio fluviale alfeo che si fa a
trasformare in acqua pura dalla sua dea
del cuore artemide che la piazza lì in
un isolotto siciliano a lei
particolarmente caro ortigia e tutti
questi personaggi che ho appena
descritto sono femmine e se ci guardiamo
attorno al museo ci accorgeremo che la
maggior parte dei reperti tradiscono
storie di donne o comunque hanno a che
fare con aspetti muliebri del vivere
antico già io faccio l'archeologa di
mestiere ho speso anni a catalogare a
studiare numerare oggetti di questo tipo
tirar fuori storie dai cocci e il mio
mestiere
quindi per me è evidente ma la domanda
che mi pongo spesso è quanti dei
cosiddetti non addetti ai lavori si
rende conto di tutto questo guazzabuglio
di storie che sta dentro questi oggetti
antichi guardo le vostre facce guardo la
faccia di lorenzo che è sempre un po
perplesso e mi do una risposta da sola
sono poche
purtroppo sono poche le persone che
riescono ad andare oltre quello che è
l'aspetto estetico di quell'oggetto e
quindi le mie donne antiche che sono
così presenti tra le vetrine di un museo
rimangono intrappolate silenziose mute
pallide e non c'è nessuno che le ascolta
e quella vetrina che li protegge
in realtà crea tra loro e il visitatore
un composto ma inevitabile distacco
e allora come fare a restituire questa
voce come fare a farle parlare io non ci
riesco con la mia arte allora mi affida
ad una musa la decima e tiro in ballo il
cinema è così faccio una telefonata e
chiamo lorenzo s io sono un regista e
cerco di raccontare delle storie lo
faccio attraverso il cinema
conoscete tutti c'erano la settima arte
è un mondo fantastico sia per chi lo
guarda come voi
si sa che per chi lo fa come me perché
il cinema è un'alchimia che attraverso
la giusta inquadratura la musica la
giusta luce riesce a dare emozioni a
dare sensazioni certo fare un
documentario archeologico non è proprio
così facile non è facile dare emozioni
con un documentario archeologico ma io
ci volevo riuscire ha visto il tema
alessandra viene da me e mi fa questa
proposta facciamo un film su culti e
miti della sicilia al femminile al
femminile fatto sono di parte è facile a
dirsi
a quel punto cosa penso penso che io ho
sempre creduto che la sicilia tradisca
un anima femminile non solo attraverso i
paesaggi attraverso i miti ma anche
attraverso le donne di questa terra che
hanno reso questa terra eccezionale
e allora stravolgo la grammatica filmica
del documentario archeologico decido di
non intervistare archeologi addetti ai
lavori che ci parleranno dei reperti dei
siti ma decido di intervistare sette
donne tutte siciliane che con
l'archeologia non avevano pressoché
nulla a che fare
le prime due che scelgo sono due donne
avanti nell'età due donne anziane donne
del presente che hanno vissuto il
passato concetta venezia e angela
guagliardo perché scelgo loro perché
potrebbero essere le nonne di ognuno di
noi raccontano delle storie raccontano
la seconda guerra mondiale quella che
noi abbiamo studiato sui libri di storia
loro l'avevano vissuta e l'hanno vissuta
a troina un paese nel cuore della
sicilia dove le bombe degli aerei anglo
americani distrussero il paese loro
persero amici parenti ma non persero la
voglia di vivere la voglia di aiutare
gli altri soprattutto angela guajardo
che alla metà degli anni cinquanta
decise decise di entrare a far parte di
un progetto pionieristico per l'epoca
diventa suora laica ed entrò nell'oasi
di troina un istituto che accoglieva
ragazzi bambini disabili che ai tempi
negli anni cinquanta le famiglie
tenevano nascosti angela si occupava
degli invisibili poi scelgo due ragazze
giovani arianna occhipinti e angela
catania hanno in comune il fatto di
essere giovani di essere determinate e
di amare la loro terra la sicilia angela
però è costretta ad andare fuori
dall'italia
una ricerca di ricercatrice archeologica
e qui in italia non riesce a fare
ricerca e allora va fuori in europa tra
sheffield e londra atene creta e li
riesce a fare ricerca poi però ci parla
della sua gela del suo paese e allora
gli occhi diventano lucidi perché lei
ama la sua terra
arianna invece per un breve periodo va
fuori dalla sicilia va a milano studia
enologia
poi torna vittoria il suo paese
d'origine in provincia di ragusa
e lì si sporca le mani di terra il mosto
a un lavoro che solo gli uomini potevano
fare queste forse le conoscete le scelgo
perché sono conosciute dal pubblico
letizia battaglia è una fotografa
simonetta agnello hornby è una
scrittrice donatella finocchiaro è
un'attrice cosa hanno in comune il fatto
di essere donne per l'arte di mettere a
disposizione dell'art il loro essere
donne e raccontare altre donne sono le
donne di letizia sono quelle immortalate
nelle sue fotografie degli anni 80 e 90
in una palermo macchiata di sangue
lei una fotoreporter e nella sua
redazione e l'unica donna che fa questo
lavoro le donne di simonetta invece sono
donne che raccontano la sicilia di altri
tempi nei suoi romanzi apparentemente
una sicilia a dominata dagli uomini ma
in effetti profondamente matriarcale
donatella invece interpreta eroina e lo
fa nel cinema e lo fa soprattutto nel
2015 nel teatro antico di siracusa dove
interpreta le supplici di eschilo donne
che si oppongono al potere degli uomini
bene donne estremamente diverse tra di
loro donne diverse per età per vissuto
per
esperienza ed estrazione sociale eppure
sette donne che hanno in comune il fatto
di essere siciliani ma soprattutto
quello di essere poste di essere
grintoso e di avere qualcosa da
raccontare di avere un segno da lasciare
qui su questa terra non solo per le
generazioni di oggi ma anche per quelle
future sono testimoni del loro tempo e
dei luoghi che le hanno viste
protagoniste esattamente come le mie
donne antiche esattamente come quei
reperti che io voglio raccontare
e allora comincio a capire che la scelta
di lorenzo che mi sembrava così strana
funziona
e sapete perché funziona perché in fondo
dietro queste micro storie c'è il
riflesso di culture di aspetti sociali
che sono relativi ad un'epoca ma che si
possono confrontare con mille altre
epoche
e allora sì che l'antico e il
contemporaneo si guardano allo specchio
e si riconoscono spesso nella voce di
queste donne ed è così che le cose delle
donne contemporanee diventano aghina
italia le cose delle donne antiche era
allora cominciò a fare degli incastri
comincia a dare voce a quei minuti
reperti e così quando angela guagliardo
dice eravamo ragazze di 22 anni fare da
mamma per noi una gioia o quando letizia
battaglia ci dice che sulla scena di un
crimine mafioso c'era sempre una madre
che piangeva il suo morto io penso che
la sicilia è una terra di madre penso ad
una statua una statua che si trova al
museo di siracusa una statua chiamata
con rothfuss di megara iblea che nome
difficile che nome greco per qualcosa
che è semplice e assolutamente non greca
è la personificazione di madre terra che
allatta che nutra i suoi figli ed è la
rappresentazione più bella e più poetica
della cultura sicula di quegli indigeni
che vivevano in sicilia prima
dell'arrivo dei coloni greci è una donna
grassa fa figli a delle mani enormi mani
che abbracciano ma che sanno anche dare
qualche sberla qualora serva è una mamma
siciliana
e a questa divinità della sicilia
preistorica i greci che arrivano qui
affiancano ma non sostituiscono del
tutto demetra un'altra mamma anche lei
divinità della natura ma di quella
domestica ta dell'agricoltura è però
succede una cosa strana incredibile in
quelle zone franche che separano le pene
coloni greche dalle ultime città sicure
salgono dei santuari di frontiera li
chiamano così dove sono soprattutto le
donne che fanno a venerare il loro the
parlano lingue diverse
offrono probabilmente doni differenti e
chiamano queste idee con nomi diversi ma
con lo stesso spirito e vedono in quella
è una mamma proprio come loro
allora cosa vuol dire che fosse donanti
che così piccole nella storia con la s
maiuscola
esistono e sono più forti di quelle
azioni di uomini come commerci e guerri
sono loro che creano il primo collante
tra popoli
sì ci rendiamo conto che dei reperti di
2500 anni fa in qualche modo ci
rimandano ai tempi nostri al nostro
quotidiano come queste figurine in
terracotta che impastano il pane al
suono del flauto e proprio segno litanie
lordi che ci racconta della facciata di
questa attività muliebre fatta
soprattutto dalle donne di impastare il
pane di preparare il pane e lo facevano
proprio cantando il canto dava ritmo a
questi gesti che si tramandano di
generazione in generazione insieme a un
pezzo di lievito madre allora come oggi
allora e oggi il presente il passato
coesistono ad esempio a siracusa in riti
e tradizioni apparentemente non legate
al mondo greco
guardate questa festa è la festa di
santa lucia delle quaglie
una festa che si svolge la prima
domenica di maggio a siracusa e solo lì
non la trovate da nessun'altra parte
durante questa festa sono loro le donne
a trasportare un pesante fercolo con
reliquiario di santa lucia
ma chi si nasconde dietro questa santa
dal nome scintillante si nasconde in
realtà una dea che era come santa lucia
la patrona di siracusa e artemide che
non è soltanto la dea della caccia ma è
soprattutto colei che con la sua fiamma
illumina il cammino di tutti quegli
individui che affrontano delle delicate
fasi di passaggio nella loro vita
soprattutto loro le donne quando
dall'infanzia passano all'adolescenza
quando si preparano al parto quando
diventano mogli e c'era una festa a
siracusa chiamata artenisio e durante
quella festa erano loro le donne
siracusane a trasportare la statua di
artemide e quindi c'è un doppio che si
ripete e non è un caso che questa santa
lucia sia delle quaglie perché ortigia
come dice il nome è ortis crea la terra
delle quaglie animale sacro ad artemide
e dunque tutto questo cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che in fondo la sicilia è
stratificata e tutto questo passato non
è mai realmente passato ce lo portiamo
appresso sotto pelle è dentro di noi e
mi accorgo finalmente del perché della
scelta di lorenzo di queste sette donne
che si portano dentro l'antico perché
l'antico non sta soltanto dentro i
reperti di un magazzino di un museo
l'antico è dentro di noi ce lo portiamo
nel nostro dna in pratica si si restando
la ci rendiamo proprio conto di questo
che il passato è nei nostri gesti e
nelle nostre parole spesso non ce ne
rendiamo conto
siamo eredi di quel passato e quel
patrimonio culturale che esso ci ha
tramandato a volte frainteso volte
maltrattato in qualche modo fa parte di
noi fa parte del nostro essere siciliani
e allora questo volevamo trasmettere le
donne di ieri le donne di oggi e direi
anche le donne di domani
fanno parte di un unico coro di una
polifonia tanto intensa tanto amabile
tanto poetica e adesso
immaginiamo di tornarci di nuovo in
questo museo però lo facciamo in punta
di piedi e con le orecchie tese le
sentiamo queste voci sono le voci di
quanti hanno tenuto fra le mani questi
oggetti di quante persone le hanno
costruite queste cose e dentro queste
frammenti ci sono le loro speranze ci
sono i loro sogni
ci sono anche le loro delusioni ei loro
ricordi ci sono cose che gli sono
appartenuti ci sono cose vostre in fondo
cos'è nostre due lorenzo e mie cose di
giovani e di anziani ci sono cose di
uomini ma soprattutto cose di donne
[Musica]
[Applauso]